Avengers endgame is here as a matter of
fact its projected to not only be number
one at the worldwide box office but it's
well on its way to having the biggest
opening of all time
fans assembled packing theaters in
Hollywood and all over the globe pushing
end games overnight box office to a
record 60 million and Counting diehards
tried to fight sleep capping off two and
a half day marathons of all 22 movies
celebs also fanned out a Captain Marvel
dressed Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott as
Ironman got daughter stormy into the act
we can't answer anything and the cast
secrecy continued to feel the fan frenzy
today do they now say okay you can go
talk about it like we could ask you what
the ending was and officially you could
tell us or no not yet nobody has said
anything to me they do I'm just gonna
keep my mouth shut
is it scary are you like please let this
movie just hit the theater so we can
talk about it I mean such a relief I
just cannot wait til the end credits
roll and then I can just like you know
sometimes sometimes sometimes not
there's a scene after the end oh my god
is there a scene I don't know but I
don't know either as weeks wait till
after this oh we just tell us something
I didn't I don't know what happens if
you give away a Marvel secret as more I
think yeah oh we know Ruffalo's a big
blabbermouth I'd find out it was him and
someone else
did it could I tell you you just you're
just rolling another Chris Evans who's
expected to hang up his shield after
earning an estimated 60 million as
Captain America appears on screen for a
reported one hour and six minutes the
most of any end game star it was
emotional III was you know and again
this has nothing to do with what happens
in the plot to here you know your raft
on the last movie just it it shook me up
[Music]
[Applause]